GILBERT STRANG: OK.
So this is a "prepare the way"
video about symmetric matrices
and complex matrices.
We'll see symmetric matrices
in second order systems
of differential equations.
Symmetric matrices are the best.
They have special
properties, and we
want to see what are the special
properties of the eigenvalues
and the eigenvectors?
And I guess the
title of this lecture
tells you what those
properties are.
So if a matrix is
symmetric-- and I'll
use capital S for a
symmetric matrix--
the first point is the
eigenvalues are real,
which is not automatic.
But it's always true if
the matrix is symmetric.
And the second, even
more special point
is that the eigenvectors are
perpendicular to each other.
Different eigenvectors
for different eigenvalues
come out perpendicular.
Those are beautiful properties.
They pay off.
So that's the symmetric matrix,
and that's what I just said.
Real lambda, orthogonal x.
Also, we could look at
antisymmetric matrices.
The transpose is
minus the matrix.
In that case, we don't
have real eigenvalues.
In fact, we are sure to have
pure, imaginary eigenvalues.
I times something on
the imaginary axis.
But again, the eigenvectors
will be orthogonal.
However, they will
also be complex.
When we have
antisymmetric matrices,
we get into complex numbers.
Can't help it, even
if the matrix is real.
And then finally is the
family of orthogonal matrices.
And those matrices have
eigenvalues of size 1,
possibly complex.
But the magnitude
of the number is 1.
And again, the eigenvectors
are orthogonal.
This is the great family of
real, imaginary, and unit
circle for the eigenvalues.
OK.
I want to do examples.
So I'll just have an
example of every one.
So there's a symmetric matrix.
There's a antisymmetric matrix.
If I transpose it,
it changes sign.
Here is a combination, not
symmetric, not antisymmetric,
but still a good matrix.
And there is an orthogonal
matrix, orthogonal columns.
And those columns have length 1.
That's why I've got the
square root of 2 in there.
So these are the
special matrices here.
Can I just draw a little
picture of the complex plane?
There is the real axis.
Here is the imaginary axis.
And here's the unit circle,
not greatly circular but close.
Now-- eigenvalues
are on the real axis
when S transpose equals S.
They're on the imaginary axis
when A transpose equals minus A.
And they're on the unit circle
when Q transpose
Q is the identity.
Q transpose is Q
inverse in this case.
Q transpose is Q inverse.
Here the transpose
is the matrix.
is minus the matrix.
And you see the
beautiful picture
of eigenvalues, where they are.
And the eigenvectors for
all of those are orthogonal.
Let me find them.
Here that symmetric matrix
has lambda as 2 and 4.
The trace is 6.
The determinant is 8.
That's the right answer.
Lambda equal 2 and 4.
And x would be 1
and minus 1 for 2.
And for 4, it's 1 and 1.
Orthogonal.
Orthogonal eigenvectors--
take the dot product of those,
you get 0 and real eigenvalues.
What about A?
Antisymmetric.
The equation I-- when I do
determinant of lambda minus A,
I get lambda squared plus
1 equals 0 for this one.
That leads me to lambda
squared plus 1 equals 0.
So that gives me lambda is
i and minus i, as promised,
on the imaginary axis.
And I guess that that matrix
is also an orthogonal matrix.
And those eigenvalues,
i and minus i,
are also on the circle.
So that A is also a Q. OK.
What are the
eigenvectors for that?
I think that the
eigenvectors turn out
to be 1 i and 1 minus i.
Oh.
Those are orthogonal.
I'll have to tell you
about orthogonality
for complex vectors.
Let me complete these examples.
What about the
eigenvalues of this one?
Well, that's an easy one.
Can you connect that to A?
B is just A plus 3
times the identity--
to put 3's on the diagonal.
So I'm expecting
here the lambdas
are-- if here they
were i and minus i.
All I've done is add 3 times the
identity, so I'm just adding 3.
I'm shifting by 3.
I'll have 3 plus
i and 3 minus i.
And the same eigenvectors.
So that's a complex number.
That matrix was not
perfectly antisymmetric.
It's not perfectly symmetric.
So that gave me a 3 plus i
somewhere not on the axis
or that axis or the circle.
Out there-- 3 plus
i and 3 minus i.
And finally, this one,
the orthogonal matrix.
What are the
eigenvalues of that?
Let's see.
I can see-- here I've added 1
times the identity, just added
the identity to minus 1, 1.
So again, I have this minus
1, 1 plus the identity.
So I would have 1 plus i and
1 minus i from the matrix.
And now I've got a division
by square root of 2,
square root of 2.
And those numbers
lambda-- you recognize
that when you see that number,
that is on the unit circle.
Where is it on the unit circle?
1 plus i.
1 plus i over square root of 2.
Square root of 2
brings it down there.
There's 1.
There's i.
Divide by square root of 2.
That puts us on the circle.
That's 1 plus i over
square root of 2.
And here is 1 plus i, 1 minus
i over square root of two.
Complex conjugates.
When I say "complex
conjugate," that means
I change every i to a minus i.
I flip across the real axis.
I'd want to do that in a minute.
So are there more lessons
to see for these examples?
Again, real eigenvalues and
real eigenvectors-- no problem.
Here, imaginary eigenvalues.
Here, complex eigenvalues.
Here, complex eigenvalues
on the circle.
On the circle.
OK.
And each of those
facts that I just
said about the location
of the eigenvalues--
it has a short proof, but maybe
I won't give the proof here.
It's the fact that
you want to remember.
Can I bring down again, just
for a moment, these main facts?
Real, from
symmetric-- imaginary,
from antisymmetric--
magnitude 1, from orthogonal.
OK.
Now I feel I've talking
about complex numbers,
and I really should say-- I
should pay attention to that.
Complex numbers.
So I have lambda as a plus ib.
What do I mean by the
"magnitude" of that number?
What's the magnitude
of lambda is a plus ib?
Again, I go along a, up b.
Here is the lambda,
the complex number.
And I want to know
the length of that.
Well, everybody knows
Thank goodness Pythagoras
lived, or his team lived.
It's the square root of
a squared plus b squared.
And notice what that-- how do I
get that number from this one?
It's important.
If I multiply a plus
ib times a minus
ib-- so I have lambda-- that's
a plus ib-- times lambda
conjugate-- that's a minus ib--
if I multiply those, that gives
me a squared plus b squared.
So I take the square
root, and this
is what I would call the
"magnitude" of lambda.
So the magnitude of a number
is that positive length.
And it can be found-- you
take the complex number
times its conjugate.
That gives you a squared
plus b squared, and then
take the square root.
Basic facts about
complex numbers.
OK.
What about complex vectors?
What is the dot product?
What is the correct
x transpose x?
Well, it's not x transpose x.
Suppose x is the vector 1 i, as
we saw that as an eigenvector.
What's the length
of that vector?
The length of that vector is
not 1 squared plus i squared.
1 squared plus i squared would
be 1 plus minus 1 would be 0.
The length of that vector
is the size of this squared
plus the size of this
squared, square root.
Here we go.
The length of x squared-- the
length of the vector squared--
will be the vector.
As always, I can find
it from a dot product.
But I have to take
the conjugate of that.
If I want the
length of x, I have
to take-- I would usually
take x transpose x, right?
If I have a real vector x,
then I find its dot product
with itself, and
Pythagoras tells me
I have the length squared.
But if the things are complex--
I want minus i times i.
I want to get lambda
times lambda bar.
I want to get a positive number.
Minus i times i is plus 1.
So I must, must do that.
So that's really what
"orthogonal" would mean.
"Orthogonal complex
vectors" mean--
"orthogonal vectors" mean that
x conjugate transpose y is 0.
That's what I mean by
"orthogonal eigenvectors"
when those eigenvectors
are complex.
I must remember to take
the complex conjugate.
And I also do it for matrices.
So if I have a symmetric
matrix-- S transpose S.
I know what that means.
But suppose S is complex.
Suppose S is complex.
Then for a complex matrix, I
would look at S bar transpose
equal S.
Every time I transpose,
if I have complex numbers,
I should take the
complex conjugate.
MATLAB does that automatically.
If you ask for x prime,
it will produce-- not just
it'll change a column to
a row with that transpose,
that prime.
And it will take the
complex conjugate.
So we must remember
always to do that.
Yeah.
And in fact, if S
was a complex matrix
but it had that property--
let me give an example.
So here's an S, an
example of that.
1, 2, i, and minus i.
So I have a complex matrix.
And if I transpose it and
take complex conjugates,
that brings me
back to S. And this
is called a "Hermitian matrix"
among other possible names.
Hermite was a important
mathematician.
He studied this
complex case, and he
understood to take the conjugate
as well as the transpose.
And sometimes I would write
it as SH in his honor.
So if I want one
symbol to do it-- SH.
In engineering, sometimes
S with a star tells me,
take the conjugate when
you transpose a matrix.
So that's main facts about-- let
me bring those main facts down
again-- orthogonal eigenvectors
and location of eigenvalues.
Now I'm ready to solve
differential equations.
Thank you.